Continental Tire coaches corner he's the
new Indiana head coach he's Archie
Miller did a great job a dating coach
for six years and now son is seven year
deal to coach the Indiana Hoosiers where
are you today Archie well I'm sitting in
my office here in Bloomington and
there's not a whole lot on the walls yet
but it's a great place do you need
something can we send you something
there to give it a little bit more of a
homely feel what do you got in mind I
don't know we can I got some around the
man cave I could probably throw your way
you fire me a gift from the man cave and
I'll put it in my office and we'll make
sure that we take good care of it be the
first item in the office in Bloomington
okay all right let's see what we can
come up with here can you believe you're
the head coach at Indiana I mean is it
sunk in not really I mean it's kind of
hard to believe because you know things
in our business they don't happen over
the course of I you know months you
don't have to you know out you don't
have months to decide you have minutes
and when the opportunity arose
conversations lead to you know face to
face you know at that point in time you
know when something like that happens
you have to be ready to go and you know
to me I was a Dayton had a great run
it's an amazing place it loves their
basketball in general but they're great
people and I would have never never
considered anything unless I felt the
opportunity was the same and gave us an
opportunity to you know take advantage
of a Final Four caliber program and so
that's why we're here right
but let me go back on what you just said
you had minutes to decide on this do you
feel like you were on the clock if you
weren't deciding to take the Indiana job
that they would have moved on no I don't
think it was anything like that I think
it was very comfortable conversation and
I knew I had made my mind that's when I
took the call that you have to be ready
to go you know you know right away on
this one if it goes in your direction
with the conversations you know work out
and I just felt really good about our
conversations with with Fred glass and
president McRobbie as well you know they
they were welcoming people they
understand Indiana basketball and you
know everything that we talked about you
know to be honest with you as I've been
here
seems to be the part so I'm excited to
be here and I'm looking forward to
building on their tradition how
important is it to keep the talent in
state because that's been an issue in
previous years it's a primary option you
know number one you know state of
Indiana the high school kids the use of
the state high school coaches you know
they in many ways have all grown up with
their eyes in Bloomington and the
program and I think that that's
something that if we can revive in a big
way and they can feel good about the way
that we do things especially the way we
treat people you know the high school
coaches that the kids you know the
grassroots programs in general I want
those guys to feel like we're good
people and we treat our we treat people
right and that's the first step in China
establish that this is a place a
destination for kids who grow up in the
state is they're not only are they going
to you know experience the great
education experience great fans but
they're also going to be around the
staff that's going to take great care of
them and develop them what did you make
of the stories that came out when it was
going to be steve alford job if he
wanted it were you already talking to
Indiana at that point oh no I had no
idea you know I think we were still
playing at the time and you know I was
really really engaged in in our season
til the end and you know once we were
dropped out of the tournament was a
tough loss to Wichita State you know I
was just taking a deep breath and went
out to San Jose and spent some time you
know with Arizona they were heading into
sweet 16 and I was hoping to stick there
for a couple days and watch those guys
have an opportunity to break through and
get to the Final Four and you know sort
of got distracted a little bit by the
Indiana you know interest and from that
point on you know things kind of took
off so I wasn't concentrating on
anything you know to be honest with the
Indiana it wasn't on my radar at the
time we were fully moving forward into
our spring at Dayton and you know
sometimes things happen for a reason and
and hopefully this one is there is a
reason it's a good one
people call you are - your real name is
Ryan do you want to give the story to
people on how we came up with a nickname
Archie
was given to me as I was a you know
really really a toddler I had a very
very bad temperament
it's very grouchy angry very few baby
pictures of me smiling and they used to
say at that time you know had the
personality of Archie Bunker and I think
that it's stuck amazingly and I don't
necessarily know if 98% of the world
even knows that my real name is Ryan
which is a true testament to a great
nickname I stick with it it's kind of
been me and it's kind of been Who I am
and other than my mom and my sisters and
maybe my sister-in-law there's just very
few people who actually call me Ryan on
a day-to-day basis
he's a Archie Miller the new Indiana
head coach you seem less sweaty than
your brother
at least on TV on the sidelines arge
well I'd say a lot of it just depends on
the venue you're in sometimes these
places are extremely hot depending on
the officiating in the game you can get
riled up and get active but you know I
tend to think that you know I can I can
handle it a little bit a little bit but
you know Sean Sean's active on the
sidelines as well and he gets into it
you know sometimes television can put
you in there in a tough spot well
congratulations on first of all the
great job you did a Dayton and I thought
you deserved Coach of the Year
consideration with what he did at Dayton
and a tough first round matchup there
for you but good luck at Indiana get him
to play some defense - Archie that'll
help - well we're gonna work on
everything and you know my hope is that
we can you know put put out there
something that this this great place and
great state can be proud of and I know
we're gonna work very hard towards it so
I appreciate it and I hope to be able to
get on again at some point in time and
your favorite movie now is Hoosiers
Archie remember that okay absolutely yes
memorize it
thank you arch that's a Ryan Miller
everybody calls him Archie all right Oh
Continental Tire Coaches Corner
for what you do Continental Tire they
they got it all for you they do it all
is that accent what you throw a little
axe out there I don't know on Coach's
Corner
coach is Coco which caught an old tire
proud sponsor exclusive tire damn
Patrick show no matter where you drive
what you drive got no tire what you do
Continental Tire dusk on the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience